i mean you
you had one hell of a [ __ ] life and
you're what in your heyday you were
having you had these drug kingpins
paying you what eight grand a week
something like that yeah that wasn't
enough basically just to tip them off on
[ __ ]
just basically and half of it i made up
because you had to produce right i mean
right like make it look like you're
actually doing something for him
right and one time it worked out that i
i saved diaz's organization one day
and who is diaz again uh adam diaz is
the dominican guy who was introduced to
me by babin perez the auto sound city
guy who ran the
auto shop where all the drug dealers
would go to his shop
how big was his organization at that
time and how what
um he probably had 30 men working for
him he had four stores
uh that he sold out of only one i knew
but
actually two so so these guys were
selling what
just coke he had three different spots
he just stole cocaine he
so he sold for four or five yeah so you
go to the grocery so
if you see the movie you could come to
my store you can get people people can
get pampers
you can get a kilo but you can get
anything at my store
his potatoes are very successful too you
can buy some cheerios
yeah but he yeah but he most of his was
weighted
he distributed mostly weight you know
but he had one or two spots because
everybody likes
you know the lower you go on the number
the higher the the profit margin is so
right he had one or two spots that sold
eight balls and stuff like that which i
didn't know about until
if i had known all i if i had known all
i found out because when you when you
get
when you get arrested you get all the
documentation from the case i was tied
into his case and i got all the
documentation from his case
you know he was pulling in a hundred
thousand a week in profit just in profit
if i had [ __ ] known
i'd get twenty thousand a week what the
[ __ ]
something i mean i'm risking my freedom
here so is that the way most of the coke
dealers worked in the city back then as
they just basically had a couple grocery
stores and they would sell coke out of
the back
bodegas with away bodegas yeah because
you can go in
right legitimately welcome to a business
and instead of
hand the money off at the register you
went to the back of the bodega and
handed them a
you had a shoebox full of you know 20s
or 50s or 100s whatever it was and
15 minutes later down down they had
hatches and shoots
they had you know like you go to the
bank and they they have this thing that
sucks
i don't know if you yeah the tube the
tube yeah they're the same thing in the
[ __ ] uh bodega
really yeah that's why and everyone was
buying like
like large amounts well that's that was
his that's his thing you know it'd be
that's how he sold like the street
dealers right oh yeah right
yeah so he would he would pick up 100
kilos and sell them in a week
and where was he getting the kilos from
um
so i didn't get that i didn't get that
to that part of the routine but from
what i hear and what he said
he got them from large distributors that
were tied to
you know the big guys uh colombians like
the medellin
yeah yeah pablo and and stuff like that
yeah that guy
that guy was pretty interesting the
documentary he had a very uh
interesting demeanor to him what like
there was like
so many there was one scenario where
uh you guys robbed or somebody
robbed a store or something like that
and there was two
there was two guys who robbed somebody
else's store
you know his cousin's store his cousin's
store or whatever and then uh
he sent you guys after after them no we
went he sent us to rob his cousin's
store because his cousin was robbing him
and but weren't taking his business
weren't there two guys that
at one point in the documentary i
remember they're asking him
what happened to these two guys that
robbed your store and he was like
they're not
franklin they're not around franklin and
coke franklin and coke yeah
yeah they're not around anymore what was
the story with those guys i don't know
they're not around anymore
is that part of the ricoh actually i
don't think so but
let's just say yes i don't know they're
not around anymore
but you were the one who tracked who
chased we got them
you got them yeah and they're not around
anymore i don't know about that part
oh okay yep but i was told they're not
around anymore okay
i mean i i i don't know i don't know but
i was told they're not around anymore
but i didn't have anything to do with
that part of it
oh okay i thought so i found them but i
so i found somebody that yeah i found
them he's over here
um got it and you just told them where
they were yeah oh
i understand yeah they're here no so
that guy was making a hundred thousand
dollars a week in profit only how much
time did he get
do you know do you remember i know i
know he did eight years initially
so and he said he wasn't sure he was he
said he was charged with money
laundering not
cocaine oh yeah so i don't know i mean i
didn't read his
papers but that's what he said and we've
spoken
to him every couple days do you really
yeah what's he doing now
he's wearing a lottery he's rolling
cigars and he's rolling in he's rolling
right here are you serious what does
that say
this the 75 right it's just the
the mind of brooklyn land of [ __ ]
brooklyn's the land of [ __ ] is that well
it says welcome to the land the [ __ ]
why is it the land of [ __ ] explain that
what does that mean okay so in the movie
that i remember that term was used yeah
so
you know that's why we put that on the
uh the t-shirt and the cigar label so is
he still in brooklyn
new york no he's been deported to dr oh
he's deported his family has a
tobacco um plantation in dominican
republic
yeah wow the largest second largest
palma palma tobacco
and who's the other guy what's his name
chino chico chico i mean chicky
chicky no the other guy the other guy
had the small little baby cartel
uh the small little drug gang the first
guy you started oh
oh yeah yeah yeah oh gosh yeah yeah he's
dead um
is he really dead yeah um they killed
him his own people kill him
oh my trying to think uh what the [ __ ]
is his name
anyway yeah that his name was like chico
or something yeah and his uh his gang
i can't remember i'm getting old his
gang was called the company
yeah i pulled him over yeah first day he
pulled him over after you found out
what hit on me he put it on he put a hit
on me and how did you how did you find
out that he put it on well first of all
he put a hit on me because he
showed me seven hundred dollars and um
so i i made it made it known that i
wasn't happy about it that he should
come up with seven hundred dollars and
he said you know [ __ ] you uh
i'm not paying you i said okay that's
fine and then i put pressure on the
store for about three days
i would park in front of the store i
chased his customers i paid another
organization another bunch of cops in
front of a store for a [ __ ] four or
five nights when i wasn't there
and chase him and bother all his clients
and then all of a sudden
my pager goes off 9-1-1 uh you know get
pages back then beepers
and it's baron's shop and then i said
what's up
he doesn't usually page me it's actually
9-1-1
he says uh you got to come see me i said
all right
i drove in to see you i was on my way to
work 4-12
and he said to me uh put a hit on you
i said oh and he said uh the [ __ ] is
that chico
chino chino yeah chino put a hit on you
and um
i said uh i said okay and uh
that i turned out my 4 to 12 shift i had
this female partner i think with me
and i said to her hold on i got to pull
this car over i never saw this car in my
life
but i knew what his car looked like
because i was told so i just took a
guess this is his car
hit the flight it was near a store
within a block of a store up by norwood
norwood and fulton if people anybody
listens nor wouldn't fulton by the
elevated drain by the station the empty
but the
staircase comes down i pulled them over
uh
i said license registration he's
reaching like he doesn't know he doesn't
know that i'm gonna kill him
he doesn't know that i want to kill him
right now and i'm hoping to see a gun
aren't you freaked out this guy's like
super
[ __ ] violent yeah nuts let's go
i'm here so i'm looking in his car and
i'm looking to see if he opens his club
park
there's a gun in the car i'm killing him
really i'm killing him
what would you do guys just said he's
going to put it on you right so i'm
killing him
and uh so he
takes he gives me his life he's like you
know hey what's my license registration
insurance card i take it from him and i
look at him and i throw it in his
[ __ ] lap
i said you put a [ __ ] hit on me
[ __ ] he looks like me oh my
heath turned as white as
i don't see it as white as a [ __ ]
t-shirt and
so anyway so i told him you know why
don't you get out of the car
i'm skinny oh sorry yeah would you a
splinter no just
my bony elmo um so i said once you get
out of the car we'll do it right here
you put a [ __ ] hit on me let's do it
right here broad daylight you and me
i said we'll do a [ __ ] mexican
[ __ ] walk off let's go shoot out yeah
[ __ ] that okay corral [ __ ] let's
go
and he's like i said you call the
[ __ ] hit off right now
or or i'm coming to see you so i gave
him a chance and he said all right all
right all right
i left i got my pay my beep my beep goes
off about 20 minutes later
he called up he pulled the head off
meanwhile the [ __ ] precinct no one
never told me
the precinct noodles was hit on me how
would they know
they got snitches everywhere bro the
feds were in that organization
somewhere what though and they never
[ __ ] told me remember
remember in the movie joe this guy
detective joe hall's in the back of a
van
and they come out the street sweepers
yeah well
there was a guy in that van that was
pointing out all the organizational
people because they
it was a snitch for them they knew that
they put a hit on me and never told me
that's [ __ ] up yeah well they didn't
want me i guess around
that's [ __ ] wild man yeah